зустрівши єгипет в університеті в
україна тільки ноди почав з чого 7 10
рук імунолога стали до піонерів і стала
черніловський тримав на університеті
саскачеван ський приводом спочив і
накладати животі зав'язки і лише пучкова
ми за скарбом із провінції плавала
ділянки заспівав профі
наука віру звідки з української мови
написання підручнику підготовка в 4 вд
для канади до української школи отримують
більше ста руки сьогодні
звучало вже теза протягнуть риба нам дошка
на вигляд та мобільність dante у наших
шанованих ec1 кислотними з таких
метушливих резерві
ми мало обмінюємося студентами на рівні
професорського окладу по складу
наука про противника та шахти сподіваюся
препараті півгодини суеца мобільності
студентів
розширення кіліка всі студенти річки
будуть нам чат і всі овочі на навчальний зал
коди канади і у нас вся душа серйозно
сьогодні проблема сама на палубу
адмініст уден там він приголомшує це натськи
партнерами сьогодні ми дискутуємо з
колегам і protea красиво дурощі туго ти
на обмін студентами і можна весь на
бути ж практичних новачок від того ж важливі в
nlhe навчання та профі синай дошки для
моєї but їх викрав і такі семінар
чудово на роки і ти хлопці лисою історія
і література то мола будете фокусі
інтересі праведних українських то
канадських вийшов і діти про
широкомасштабно співаючи проти технічних
спеціально стоїть так природно чиїх наук
1000 сьогодні у нас більше 40
університеті України представлені нації
з уст мови говорити про прапорщика віза
цекало не зміг і українських вищих
початкових затемненням обладунок брати з
канадським університетом
а за іншалла боку з я червоне обожнювання
ворогів та чаю та політичні
складу we розвитку а світло їх послав
збив ти можна його стиль ще до
рухливих диплом в рахунок зростання тка наука
ви з комори університеті ще раз
більше не кличуть іноземних студентів
і до наших українців не встати сьогодні
премії біля води тисне 275 університетів
україни до-канада які нас ми на
дмитро поцілунків гама новими